j'en retiens juste après 6 heures
sébastien monsieur yassine belattar sur
twitter justement publiquement dit que
j'ai une tête de chat mauger une fête
bougnol ntela et aucune des belges
aucune des belles âmes antiraciste n'est
là pour dire mais c'est scandaleux
j'aurais dit un truc pareil
mais on mourait voler dans les pas la
regarder notre est-ce qu'on peut revoir
le clip de yacine s'il vous plaît et
vous les mettez vous mettez le mauvais
tweet alors non mais dans le tweet de
yann zimbra celui là c'est toujours que
tu dois celle qui dit dit voilà alors
parce que vous avez dit yassine belattar
avec ta tête de chameau qui se permet
d'insulter la terre entière
les insultes racistes tu ose encore la
ramener quand insulté par le type de
nocibé puisque on reviendra là dessus
aussi b la marque de cosmétiques tu
aurais pu avoir la décence de la fermer
mais bon l'islamisme et yacine répondu
tu es un génie
jean messia c'est même plus même plus
marrant t3 rap pour les fachos était
trop raciste pour les arabes ta place
est entre les deux égaré que tu es avec
ta tête de l'eau combe aux marines
voilà alors j'en ris et maroc tout le
monde s'adapte aux trouve ça drôle ont
signalé j'aurais vu jésus était obligé
de porter un pin's de la france pour
qu'on sache que tu es le français
toujours mon cousin qui vit ses biceps
c'est encore raciste mais ces petits
délices tu es un raciste c'est l'adn de
l'islamisme tu es bon oui mais tu as far
as c'est pas ça c'est que tu considères
les personnes qui sont assimilés
quasiment comme étant des traîtres et
moi je sens en moi je considère lé
inverse c'est à dire que tu vis en
france tu as la nationalité française
le fait de pacte comporter comme un
français parce qu'il ya une identité
française comme il ya une identité
marocaine communauté in hand identité
algérienne
le fait de pâtes comporter conformément
à l'identité du pays dont tu portes la
citoyenneté fait de toi un traître mais
pas celui qui ça c'est les gens
regardent vraiment soyons objectifs on
regarde juste une question de quoi tu
tenais ou mais c'est pas la question
rennais où c'est pas la question tenait
où je suis né au caire est arrivé à quel
âge à une garde à vue
ça fait huit ans de plus que moi mais
c'est pareil c'est pas la question à moi
je suis né en france mais c'est pas la
face à lyon la soie loup bouche avec la
question je t'écoute
écoutez bon déjà déjà déjà un tu me dont
11 vous voit on se tutoie pas un couard
est voilà non et je vais te dire un truc
et qui va pas te plaire pour tout un tas
de raisons tu connais la principale on
n'a pas gardé les cochons ensemble
et bah c'est bien la preuve que tu es
assis voilà ce que je garde mes cochons
mais voilà exactement comme c'est ce que
je te dis c'est que si tu sais pourquoi
parce que je gardais faisais tu sais que
l'été c'est pourquoi et je garde michel
mercier fait savoir m
et c'est donc d'être assimilée à la
france quand tu vis en france excuse moi
mais le haut niveau légal mais il ne
peut pas éliminer si vous le voulez
parce que j'aime beaucoup notre langue
et il s'avère que l offre plein de
nuances garder le vouvoiement
nettoiement madame bongo rousse bref
juste vous dire quelque chose on cherche
bonbons c'est moi vous êtes assimilé par
sept personnes qui s'enfonce au fur à
mesure de l'émission est magnifique avec
son tailleur oui non mais vous irez la
mélodie nom même adresse que vous me
dites aurait bon vous voyez la
considération qu'il a pour les femmes
vous êtes la shoah ça veut dire que
menacé de mort vous me dites parti je
mets un foulard rose
comment faites-vous le genre je finis
avec jean parce qu'on sait jamais vu et
là c'est un moment speed de la 2d vous
aviez vous aviez jamais vu l'élève où
finit la vertu trois frères vous étiez
jamais vu mes gars zidane et lui que je
voulais vendre yaziji moi qui a du
talent
[Applaudissements]
moi pour moi je vois pas jean mathia je
dis la vérité
pour moi je vois ni camp parce que t'es
pas français mais non voilà c'est super
et c'est pas parce que vous le dites que
je le suis plus mais non il s'avère que
moi je suis français tout le temps
j'aime la france de dunkerque à
marseille
j'aime la scène bah c'est dommage ça
s'entend pas et ça ne se voit pas
j'aimerais bien mettre à un pin's
mais moi j'en doute pas la question vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure vous êtes nés
ou mais quand on arrive en france et
comprend la nationalité d'un pays c'est
bien pour devenir membre de la
communauté nationale de ce pays oui si
vous voulez rester ce que vous êtes
resté ce que vous êtes dans votre pays
voilà vg10 à lui voilà mais c'est
logique que les champs moi j'ai pas
envoyé de papier pour être français mais
que vous avez fait c'est pas les a
renvoyés non damée genre voici que ça
fait vraiment assimilé
mais si ça vole et cia voulait comme
messi avec car vous voulez je vous dise
pourquoi j'ai changé de prénom
allez j'ai changé de prénom pour entrer
emplois que parce que la mouvance la
mouvance que vous représentez devenir
très subtil pour vous en régie pour vous
il représente on est allé frères
musulmans et bien effectivement bas
attendait quand on touche quand on
soutient le ccf
mais ça va vous adaptez voilà quand vous
teyssou tcc y est vous n'allez pas me
dire vous êtes membre du crif n'a pointé
les conneries bah alors voilà je sais
pas là vous parlez de 6 tout ça me
soutenez les s'essayait entre
parenthèses le ccr pour tous les
attentats qui ont eu lieu islamiste n'a
pas eu un mot gens je suis maintenant
mais maintenant ça vous vous égarez
jamais cherché logo jean messia genre et
sa souplesse
non on parle pas du crif sinon jean luc
mélenchon va encore dire une connerie
venu donc c'est bon ils ont la passion
du chant il en a assez dit comme ça jean
luc mélenchon qui réussiront ils à quoi
tient le crif qui représente que
lui-même
non mais jean luc mélenchon 6 nations à
résidence on a vu le 12 avril a dit jean
luc mélenchon sait et on va s'assurer sa
meilleure sortie
je pense qu'il aurait mieux fait de
rester chez lui il franchit les
meilleurs avec les huissiers bah oui
yacine je comprends quand j'essaie de
répondre mon jeu je confirme carnet
d'honoré moi mais je comprends
parfaitement qu'un mec que moi constitue
dans son logiciel une sorte de bugs on
se rends tu tentes à dire c'est à dire
c'est à dire oui exactement bah oui
parce que tu l'a initié à l'autre est
rien de souci je t'aime tu es mon frère
m mcg la france ni bagdad - moi t'es pas
mon frère parce qu'on n'a aucun lien
famille les seinomarins concepteurs
espèrent jaurès vous reprochez à la sim
data
alors il y as dont dans la lecture des
frères musulmans de l'islam alors je
suis pas frères musulmans moi je sais tu
serais rebondi danois qui sont visés je
n'ai pas parlé fort gg pas parler toi là
je parle des frères mahmoud et soit 8
déjà c'est une preuve bon dans la
lecture des feux de la dent light
frériste de l'islam
quelque chose qui s'appelle l'art de la
dissimulation accueillez en arabe
tu connais il parle arié le chpj subi
lingue donc comme ça j'ai parfois c'est
très grave ses bras française adressée
par un psy c'est très français par des
gaulois france émis lundi au quai
d'orsay on a des arabisants
extraordinaire ailleurs aussi et donc
alors à les gens allez on enchaîne donc
les lectures cas vis de l'islam est un
truc s'appelle la taqiyya c'est l'art de
la dissimulation
la question que je voudrais te poser ce
soir c est ce que tu n'as pas enrichi
cette notion du métier d'humoriste
c'est à dire qu'à travers le métier
d'humoriste vous tue pratiquer une sorte
de taqiyya et j'ai entendu le début de
l'émission
on voit bien qu'ils étaient toujours
tangente est toujours entre deux hôtes
et toujours c'est toujours très ambigu
ton discours elle sait parfaitement ça
rentre parfaitement dans la théorie de
sayyed qutb qui est un des grands
intérêts connaissent pas l'islam et
attend te la joues pas tu connais sa
jambe à tête sayed code tu connais pas
ben pour moi c'est l'arrière gauche de
lille mais ça c'est des internautes
ça c'est exactement comme les menaces de
mort que tu reçois par milliers mais
dont personne sait lesquels sont bons
mais mes céréales a nommé jean vareilles
van houtte à questions auxquelles
s'adonnent à la question que tu venais
pour lui poser une caisse que tu
pratiques à travers ton métier
d'humoriste moins une forme
contemporaine de ce que lui la théorie
frériste
l'islam appelle la tati ya oui ou non la
plage traquer les faits n'auraient pas
leur juste pour déconstruire puisque
c'est je cherche une première partie si
demain tu es libre aux théâtre de dix
heures je peux te prendre la taqiyya ça
serait la stratégie que les musulmans
ils veulent prendre le pouvoir mais même
les musulmans sont pas au courant c'est
un musulman c'est pas drôle et des
musulmans
j'ai parlé de la malibu est restée
malaisie namyst mais c'est d'aller vers
une ou catch là des fois il y en a deux
défauts il y en a je finis avec moi tu
reviens je reviens je bats tu piges les
octogone on a tu kiffes les octogone ont
alors si tu confonds booba yassine
belattar je suis pas je suis hexagone
mais je parlais d'un octobre jour je
vais te dire qu'avant les indes en
octobre et d'intellectuels évidemment
aller il n'y a pas d'hopital et moi
d'humour l'asie un humour je te laisse
les races juste dire quelque chose hein
c'est pas un mois voilà il s'avère que
il y a quelques mois on s'est vu avec
mon cyril oui et on s'est vus parce que
tout simplement moi je faisais une
émission si on a vu qu'ils s'appellent
nova avec toute l'estimé que j'ai pour
radio orient que les autres radios qui
n'est pas connu pour être une radio
communautaire
donc moi j'ai fait trois morts chinois
les missions exceptionnelles s'appelle
les trente glorieuses qui est maintenant
sur deezer qui s'appelle l'heure de
gloire
toutes les semaines je fais des
émissions et dans mes émissions jeu j'ai
un double discours que je fais des
vannes avec des mecs qui s'appelle
benjamin tranier avec des mecs qui
s'appelle nabil avec des mecs qui
s'appelle bouamatou et j'aimerais je
vais te décevoir je sais que tu pars du
principe que j'ai une double un double
discours moi je pars du principe que
certaines personnes comme toi oui ou une
double audition
c'est à dire que c'est toi qui entend
des choses que je n'ai jamais dit j'ai -
jeanne d'arc mais pas à ce point non
mais je sais que c'est le symbole de ton
parti donc respecté juste te dire
qu'elle ne tenait pas compte mais y'a
pas de soucis mots si j'en ai pas honte
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je sais que tu ne
veux pas l'entendre
je peux comprendre que tu est redevable
à la france jean parce que tu es venu
d'un pays autre étude étaient installés
en france
moi je suis né français bauthian jules
car menaçant mais ils ont fermé ou un
cri la marseillaise carte nationale
d'identité et moi je dois être une carte
mais où est la nation et où l'identité
mais tu veux quoi tu marques contre le
brésil à saint denis avec zidane
cctc quoi enfin je mets tu crois que
mais moi je suis français tout le temps
j'ai pas besoin d'un coup de jeune homme
et ça se voit pas juste aubry 500
dijon vous combattrez jusqu'au bout tous
les gens qui se disent patriotes c'est
un mot que ma génération que ça soit les
jimmy que ce soit karim qui a milité que
ça soit nos grands frères dans les
quartiers que ce soit les frères de la
marche des beurs que ce soit tous ceux
qui lèvent la tête que ça soit cyril
dans sa manière de donner la parole à
certaines personnes que d'autres médias
ne veulent pas invité nous sommes la
france
quand mon grand père tabasser des nazis
le jet est en train de rater au caire ou
bien j'ai un nez dès midi les anglais
aujourd'hui on sait depuis tu n'en sais
rien non mais je te dis un moment où au
moins été enrôlé dans l'armée
britannique est là pour battue romaine
lors des deux derniers départs alors
pourquoi pas rêver à des graines riches
comme bien ce que je te dis j'en sais qu
un moment tu es là en train de
distribuer pardon c'est à dire ça tu es
l'idiot utile d'un parti de racisme non
toi toi tu es l'idiot et un régime de
visas les objets mais tu devais prendre
la tête de la mairie de paris constaté
pourquoi mais non mais on espère la sadc
chiant la tuer com - man u new look les
un [ __ ] pas vrai mais je te le fais
c'est parce qu'à l'aspect genre ces gens
lorsqu à paris georges est encore
rassemblement national ne fait pas de
score c'est une campagne qui coûte cher
mais on ne peut pas prendre le risque de
faire une campagne qui coûte in
vértiable pour faire moins de 500 fcfa
c'est surtout les électeurs de barbès et
je le sais pour la référence je rentre
d'une tournée dans les fédérations du
rassemblement où je suis très bien et
puis par les militants
je sais bien comment y avait dans mes
cheveux je t'invite louncény nabé la
rochelle jamais être à lyon je vais
travail je vais être a permis aux nous
viens avec moi et j'en conviens avec
rome au bar mais via un média sérieux
arrêt au moins tu verras comment méchant
je suis accueilli la vérité c'est qu'au
rassemblement national il n'y a pas de
racistes il ya des retombées enfin ceux
qui ne sont pas pures et voilà racistes
au front national
non non en fait des guerres lancées sur
la zonda tantôt mais oui mais ça c'est
ça c'est toi pierre assists en disant ça
mais ça c'est pas la france mais
simplement mais sa part la france a
saisi et les caméras et les winners
alors j'ai juste une question à te poser
tu dis que tu vas te battre contre huit
dernières courses urgent alors est-ce
que ce même discours
tu le tiendrait au maroc s'il y avait
une minorité chrétienne par exemple ou
juive au maroc avec un type qui
s'appellerait yassine belattar local
mais qui ouvre ou un prénom plutôt un
nom plutôt chrétiens qui se balade avec
une croix comme toi tu te balades à
barbe et qui tient le même discours que
toi par jour est à porter ça là c'était
le premier au maroc a critiqué cette
personne est à dire il faut défendre
l'identité marocaine
alors pourquoi ce que tu acceptes dans
ton pays dans le pays d'origine de tes
parents tu le refusa la france pourquoi
est-ce que tu qualifies de nationalisme
de patriotisme et où l'encouragent dans
tous les pays de la terre pourquoi tu
veux l'interdire la france mais moi ça
ça y est tu as fini bagdad a mis tous
les ingrédients métabolisé par exemple
il m'a dit pas buzz du jour laissé leur
répondent cette fois c'est aller vers
les gens moi je suis contente de voir je
sais pas toi tu sais pas s'il a fait pas
quand je te parle si tu te sens
islamisés avec les frères musulmans
non non moi je freine je suis immunisé
de longue date chez raoui l'absolu
boraine maladie la mise en scène
si j'arrive à voir d'autres questions
parce qu'on va liberia si je suis né en
france
j'aime la france j'aime vraiment la
france d'accord je suis père de famille
où tout ça ça te dépasse quand je te dis
combattre les patriots et qu' il a fallu
se battre longtemps et karine qu'une
coupe si j'ai tort vous nous avez
préempter des mots patriotisme drapeau
on pouvait même pas se revendiquer dans
la porte en a fait les frais dans les
quartiers aujourd'hui
pendant longtemps le symbole du drapeau
était un symbole qui nous renvoyait
quelque part au front national
je suis un battant je vais au bout mais
c'est juste parce que le vivre je suis
désolé tapez wikipédia fait descendre la
souris avant marine le pen y avait un
mec qui s'appelait jean marie le pen
d'accord donc un moment jean marie le
pen pardon te dire ça il a fait des
choses
en tout cas à une partie des français
qui sont de confession musulmane ou
autres qui ont fait qu'on sait pas tout
de suite senti accord pour vous je
finissais juste quelque chose
moi j'ai un choc émotionnel politique
pour répondre à eric naulleau de manière
tout à fait bienveillance je vais vous
dire quelque chose avec mollo moi je
suis né en 80 de mon choc émotionnel
politique qui fait que un jour j'ai
décidé de m'engager rose on a quasiment
le même âge donc on fait partie de ce
choc c'est qu'un jour je me suis
réveillé
avril 2002 j'ai allumé ma télé il y
avait jean marie le pen
et là je me suis dit yacine soit tu
continues à fermer ta gueule
dans une france parallèle et tu passes
ta vie à dire ouais la france ceci cela
soit tu fais en sorte de ferme ou partie
des composantes de ce pays là tout ce
que je fais je le bris au nom de la
france mais je ne m'attends c'est
marrant je ne t'entends jamais proclamé
ta fierté d'être français comme je t'en
es ce que ces fiers d'être français de
la mi mandat de quatre ans il a déjà
trois allons enfants de un temps souvent
proclamer avec verve et faconde la
fierté de ses origines
jamais je ne t'entends proclamé
d'affaires français méritants gaza mais
elle à tapas jamel debbouze devant toi
hein j'ai acheté du québec
moi je vais et humour tes origines en
bon doublés par et je suis la france et
je suis mais juste si tu me suis sur
twitter ou le maintien au coup d'état
tête a courageusement verrouiller ses
revenus de suivre un moment ton armée de
clones la star wars je te dis juste
qu'il a nommé guy léger léger les
marathons service un de ton côté hockey
youssef balle ricky un journaliste qui
est enfermé jusqu'à il ya très très peu
de temps au maroc a été un journaliste
elle était enfermée pour un tweet
concernant ce qui s'est passé en irak
dans le rif marocain je peux dire que
c'est pas trés marocain est très soutien
du pouvoir que de tweets et libéré de
ceux badri je suis très fier moi je
pense
et pour te dire à quel point je suis
beaucoup plus progressiste que toi que
les notions de france précise sans rien
dire ok bon ben si tu as largement
régressé histoire ainsi aujourd'hui la
discussion elle et moi je suis pas pour
les partis
je trouve que la gauche nous a acculé
dans une espèce de bienveillant ou
bienveillance mais le à nous donner des
gymnases d'accord avec du qatar et du
manga en dix ans c'est ça la france ou
non il s'avère que être français c'est
complexe
il ya des mecs de quartiers qui sont des
libéraux des chefs d'entreprise comme il
ya des mecs de quartiers qui sont des
communistes jamais qu'ils manifestent le
week-end mais jamais ce que je veux dire
par là un jean pour que tu le
comprennent un moment la réalité c'est
pas être français c'est pas le dire
c'est comme avec les femmes et je sais
pas comment tu es avec ta femme dire je
t'aime c'est pas une preuve lui montrer
tous les jours c'est différent et c'est
de faire l'amour voilà c'est parce que
10 c'est parce que dit la théorie à
laquelle tu à l'heure à laquelle tu
pratiques et tu connais la viktwa mes
yeux le nez la blague et les blancs
durant chez toi le soir hba ta femme si
elle sait pas pourquoi toi tu le sais si
toi tu es bon tu peux aller le sait
alors s'accélère
alors non j'ai pas compris la blague
alors juste et j'aime bien qui sera
demain dans la grosse rigolade haye
c'est ça c'est ça les vannes que tu fais
à marseille on sait les mannequins mais
moi je suis pas humoriste en live live